الحوثيون يفون بوعدهم في البحر الاحمر
اسبانيا تعلن الوقوف مع القطاع ضد
العبريين دوليا وتل ابيب تصرح ما نقوم به
في الجنوب يمكن ان ينجح بشكل افضل في
الشمال مجمع الشفاء الطبي يضع واشنطن في
ورطه النتنياهو يرد على اردوغان للمره
الاولى وقطر تقترب من عقد اتفاق عبري مع
الفصائل خلاف امريكي بريطاني حاد والسبب
زيلينسكي قرار تاريخي لبوتين يهز النظام
العالمي الذي بنته واشنطن موسكو تضع موعدا
للنهايه الحتميه للدعم الامريكي لكيف وزل
نسكي يحذر مواطنيه مما هو اقسى الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتحضر لحزمه عقوبات جديده ضد
الروس هل من جديد قبل ان يلتقي بايدن
يهاجم الرئيس
الصيني واشنطن في موقف
محرج عمليه شدت انظار العالم نحوها
انتقدتها معظم دول العالم وبين شجب وتنديد
انتهت العمليه وبعد ان خرج الجيش العبري
من مجمع الشفاء الطبي قال مصدر طبي في
المجمع لبي بي سي ان الجيش العبري انسحب
من داخل المجمع واعاد نشر دباباته وقواته
في محيطه من الخارج فيما افادت اذاعه
الجيش العبري بانه لا يوجد ما يشير الى
وجود مختطفين داخل مستشفى الشفاء وان
عمليات المسح مستمر هنا وبعد انتهاء عمليه
الاقتحام دون جدوى شعرت امريكا بالوره فقد
قال البيت الابيض ان واشنطن لم توافق على
العمليه العبريه في مستشفى الشفاء وذلك
بعد ان ادعت واشنطن قبل ساعات من اقتحام
العبريين لاكبر مجمع طبي في القطاع ان
لديها معلومات استخباراتيه تؤكد تورط
الفصائل في استخدام المستشفى لاغراض
عسكريه هذا وكان محيط البيت الابيض في
واشنطن قد شهد احتجاجات على اقتحان الجيش
العبري لمجمع الشفاء الطبي بالقطاع هذا
واعلن المدير العام للمستشفيات بالقط قطاع
محمد زقوت ان الجيش العبري طرد الاطفال
والمرضى من مشفي يي الشفاء والرنتيسي
بينما خرج نتنياهو ليرد على الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان الذي كثرت انتقاداته
اللاذعه لتل ابيب مؤخرا بقوله اردوغان
نفسه فجر قر تركيه فلا نقبل منه الموعظه
بالمواقف الدوليه طالب رئيس الوزراء
الاسباني بيدرو سانتشيز تل ابيب بوقف
القتل الاعمال المدنيين في القطاع معلنا
ان حكومته ستعمل في اوروبا واسبانيا من
اجل الاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه فيما
افادت رويترز بان قطر تسعى لاتفاق بين
تلبيب والفصائل لاطلاق سراح 50 راهنه
مقابل وقف اطلاق النار ثلاثه ايام وبموجب
الاتفاق المحتمل ستفرج تل ابيب عن بعض
النساء والاطفال من سجونها هنا وبعد
البيان الاخير للحوثيين عن الهجوم على اي
سفينه عبريه في البحر الاحمر صرح متحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بان المدمره
هادن تصدت مسيره انطلقت من اليمن ودمرتها
وكانت تحلق باتجاه المدمره بالقرب من باب
المندب في البحر الاحمر ميدانيا اعلنت
وزاره الامن القومي العبري ان طلبات
الحصول على تصاريح حمل الاسلحه ارتفعت
بشكل كبير في تلابيب وانها اصدرت اكثر من
31 الف رخصه سلاح للمستوطنين منذ السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي وقال وزير الخارجيه
العبري ايي كوهين ان تلبيب لا تنوي اعاده
فتح معبري كرم ابو سالم وايرز مع القطاع
بعد الحرب فيما هدد عضو حكومه الحرب وزير
الدفاع العبري السابق بيني جانس مقاومه
لبنان قائلا ما نقوم به في الجنوب يمكن ان
ينجح بشكل افضل في الشمال ولفت الى انه
حتى لو اضطررنا الى وقف اطلاق النار
لاستعاده اسرانا ولكن الحرب لن تنتهي حتى
تحقيق اهدافنا لننتقل الى الولايات
المتحده وقبل ان يلتقي الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بنظيره الصيني شيجين بينغ اعلن
بايدن ان الصين في دي شيجين بين تعاني
مشاكل فعليه في تصريح غريب عشيه قمه بالغه
الاهميه بين رئيسي اكبر قوتين اقتصاديتين
في العالم خلاف الحلفاء اوكرانيا امام وضع
صعب وتحذير من الداخل هذه المره حيث حذر
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلنسكي
مواطنيه من هجمات روسيه محتمله على البنيه
التحتيه مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء منبها الى
ضروره الاستعداد لشتاء قاس و مواجهات
جديده هذا وصرح نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي دمتري مدفيدف ان الدعم الامريكي
لنظام كيف يقترب من نهايته الحتميه وهذا
لن يحدث مباشره ولكن الاتجاه واضح بهذا
الخصوص مضيفا امريكا تخون بسهوله ابنائها
اللقطا عندما يصبحون عديمي الفائده من جهه
اخرى اكد المستشار الالماني وف شولس انه
يتوجب على اوكرانيا الامتثال امتثالا تاما
لجميع متطلبات الانضمام الى الاتحاد الا
الاوبي على الارض نشرت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه مقطع فيديو يظهر قيام القوات
الروسيه بتدمير معقل تابع للجيش الاكراني
على محور كرسني ليمان فيما افاد اوليك
سوسكين المستشار السابق للرئيس الاوكراني
الاسبق ليونيت كوتشما بان تكتيكات زيلنسكي
ادت الى فشل الهجوم المضاد للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وليس ذلك فحسب بل لم تتمكن
ايضا من الحفاظ على سيطرتها على جميع
مواقعها لتعود الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن ان
الجيش الروسي دمر رادار منظومه اس 300
وثلاث نقاط مراقبه تابعه للواء الميكانيكي
67 واللواء العمليه 31 وفوج الحرس الوطني
50 بالقرب من سير برينكا الرد ياتي من
اوروبا حيث سلمت المفوضيه الاوروبيه للدول
الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي مقترحات
بخصوص حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه الثانيه
المقترح فرضها على روسيا وتشمل حظرا جديدا
على الواردات والصادرات واجراءات لتشديد
رقابه على اسعار النفط واجراءات صارمه ضد
شركات الطرف الثالث التي تتحايل على
العقوبات بالعوده الى مواقف الغرب بشان
اوكرانيا ذكرت وسائل اعلام نقلا عن الضابط
في وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
لاري جونسون ان واشنطن ولندن اختلفتا حول
من يجب ان يخلف زيلينسكي في رئاسه
اوكرانيا ويبدو ان بريطانيا وضعت رهاناتها
على القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه زوجني بحسب جونسون لازلنا في
امريكا حيث ذكرت وسائل اعلام امريكيه ان
قرار الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بسحب
بلاده من معاهده الحظر الشامل للتجارب
النوويه هز النظام العالمي الذي بنته
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اما في روسيا
فاكد الرئيس الروسي بوتين خلال اجتماعه مع
ممثلي اللجان الانتخابيه انه سيتم قمع اي
محاولات للتدخل الخارجي والداخلي في
العمليه الانتخابيه في روسيا الاتحاديه